yeah once again i'm accepting
i'm accepting uh three minutes and five
minute challenges from from premium
members so
if if you do not meet those
uh criteria you're not gonna you're not
gonna be able to
play unfortunately
okay so this is art
with some numbers from belgium
um okay let's just
try and play pretty classical uh
once again uh b6 this is a
somewhat unusual move order but i think
at the end of the day
we're going to get one of the good old
lines of the
queen's indian that gary
popularized back in the day
and yeah this is the uh
classical way of playing it as uh as
black now
you usually go c5
wondering briefly if i don't think
that's the way people play
but if e5 probably e5 h6 is nothing
nothing special anyway i think i'm just
gonna castle
and uh the wide position
looks quite quite uh appealing here
with uh with a pretty pretty big center
but uh usually in practice it's not it's
not
that easy and black
it's fairly easy development and
some some possibilities of attacking
attacking them
um the the white center queen c7
um i can't say i like that move
at all actually since you're sort of
begging for
d5 um to be played it looks fairly
similar to an old game
of garys vs portish
where he played d5 everything was
blasted open after
ed5 ed5 um eventually going
for bishop g7 later on uh and winning
winning a beautiful game i think it's
just too too tempting here to go d5 so i
sort of
sort of have to have to do it
if if cd uh sorry if ede
it's already looking pretty dicey for
for black i would say
knight a5 um and then
yeah after queen e4 i probably have to
play g6
which looks to me at least
very dubious so knight a5
he quite correctly does uh that's that's
a lot
lot better um not opening up the
diagonal for
my bishop on d3 but he does leave
himself with a pretty
glary glaring weakness on
[Music]
on on e6 so i think i should be doing
very well
here you see another one of the
disadvantages of queen
c7 which is that he has to spend
another move uh defending it with um
with queen d7 and even on d7 i would say
the queen is not
particularly safe since bishop b5 is a
massive threat now
and if knight c6
um there would have been bishop takes e6
followed by
bishop c4 winning the queen
so now i i think i'm still gonna go
bishop b5
and if queen queen two
yeah queen f7 is probably decent i was
hoping for queen e7 and then
um maybe i could have gone knight f5
there
ef5 and then rook d7 it was queen g5
there but at the very least it looks
tempting
i can see now that i'm very short on
time um
[Music]
a natural result of me yapping um
too much so i'm going to have to to
speed up here
still rook d7 is a massive massive
threat
f7 i'm just going to go rook d1
maybe bishop e5 was was an option there
as well
uh maybe i missed out there
okay i can't think okay i'll just take
off seven
maybe you can take an e4 now
as is getting getting out of hand in a
major way
we'll give a check hope for the best
okay we'll take
d3 95 next this has gotten
ugly
but he's yeah he's taking a lot of time
g3 now at least my position is
improving quite a bit
okay we'll just have have to hope for a
quick attack here
also he he's quickly running out of time
as well
attending bishop a3 at some point
give a check he's defending well but i
think he's gonna lose some time
okay yeah he just wasn't very wasn't
very fast
um uh but uh
in general there i think it was a good
game for
for a while but then obviously turned
out to be
turned out into a bit of a ridiculous
scramble